do you miss your father
think about him
when I think about him I do now when do
I think about him
thought about him yesterday
working through a script I'm working on
right now working on scene work and I
just had that quick little reaction of
wanting to show him hey check this thing
that's right and then I
I don't get sad I go yeah he would have
loved he would have loved this
where's my mom
wants to be on the stage my dad would
have been on the front row
he's more fun to show stuff too yeah and
he would have and you know as as what he
would we would have he knew he was a
character he knew characters I've based
parts of all kinds of characters I've
played in them and the man that that I
am on people that he introduced me too
and who he was
um he would have loved the creative
process of working on a script or or
talking about hey movie do I always say
I love the movie Mud
because it's the one that I I visualized
and seen my dad come to me so many times
as a 12 year old and put his arm around
and go hey little buddy you've seen this
movie called Mud God damn it it's a good
one let's go watch it
that now my dad was never got to see me
start a career in film but he was alive
five days
into the over he overlapped the first
five days of me working on my first film
days confused now that I think is
There's Something Beautiful about that
he didn't never ever come to the set we
didn't talk about it
but he was alive
for me to start something that was more
than uh
uh more than a fad that was something
that would become something that I love
to do and I do miss
not him you know and then I go out of
that do I I I we talked about him two
nights ago
with our with our daughter I was I was
rubbing my daughter's feet
and my mom is living with this 91 comes
in goes oh look at you just like your
pop
he was like what he goes oh because my
dad loved her
rub somebody's feet rub my mom's feet
rubbed all
of me and my brother's girlfriend's feet
when we would have a date yeah
they would come over early
because they knew they were going to get
a foot rub from Jim McConaughey and then
we'd come out me and Matilda Brothers on
this has been on for decades we come out
a shot ready to go buttoned up and
they're looking I'm like oh we ain't
going anywhere right now
and so we told the story you know to my
to my daughter and I was like oh yeah my
dad's his hands and miss his hands his
hands could heal so you carry him in you
I hope so
I I I hope so and in
it's a uh
a challenge
for me and I suppose it's like this for
any
Sun
how much do we hang on to
and how much do we let go
involve and update the OS and and and
and and and and try it maybe better or
different
you know
it's that there's certain things that I
know that I fully believe in it's like
when do we religious when do we Cast
Away Our Father
you know when do we say no I'm going
after the dream I'm not asking your
permission
I I I I
question that from time to time for
myself because I and it almost feels
blasphemic if that's a word sometimes I
feel like you can't what are you doing
you can't check that and go like well no
I'm not sure if I want it really
and then I immediately kind of let
myself off because I believe where he is
he's going
go but yeah go you're free man yeah
you're not I'm not not the one I'm not
gonna hold you back if you misread that
or I didn't teach you that as well as
maybe I wish I could have go you're free
you're not gonna lose trust that you're
not gonna lose it's in your DNA it's in
your lineage young man
still it's scary to not have a safety
net losing your father is scary in that
way you realize this world is just you
and some deep fundamental way is just
you
yeah you're alone
yes
but I mean also not having that
such a gift of Deliverance though
as well
because it's a
I think it's an I mean
it's an awesome feeling to know
to know we're alone to know we don't
have that to know you don't have to take
two
or take three that it's one take I mean
the peripheral vision
improves
you know the the the the the
link and understanding with our past
improves because I know for me I was not
ever considerate of my past at all
because that my dad had that
if I needed it he was my well for that
well he's gone you know I said he had
the literally had they have our back
well then when they longer have our back
also I'm going like oh maybe I need to
look back and start giving some credit
to how I got here
what I'm doing and where I'm heading it
gave me the first time courage to even
look over my shoulder
because again I didn't have to because I
don't have to look dad's got my back oh
Dad gone
from this life he doesn't have your back
okay
so I mean
I don't know me because
it's inevitable I
I very quickly go to
all right in the in the pain the loss
and yes
even loan leanness which is different
from being alone
and loss
pretty immediately part and parcel with
the pain I felt it
in the pain you saw the gift the the red
light of losing your losing your father
pretty immediately less impressed more
involved I came like
a couple weeks
after moving on
is there a trick to that to see the gift
and the pain that's a good question is
is there a trick to it
not that I know of
I mean I don't
I have to I I
have to catch myself from
trying to intellectualize my way into
the reasoning
and not skip over real
feelings and discomfort
I mean I I did get that from my mom and
I have to watch it that that so
resilient that we just dust ourselves
off and get up and go
you want to sit in the feeling you want
to feel it you want to deeply feel the
pain I want to I want to deeply feel it
I want to look at the eye and deeply
feel it
but I don't want to wallow in it yeah
um now I was raised where you skipped
the deeply feel and let's go
and I've said it before but that will
lead to having
turned into a person who is a repeat
offender of the same crimes because you
you just get up and you don't
you don't have a winter in your life you
know what I mean you don't have you
there's no introspective time you don't
look over your shoulder at the end of
the past and so you just get up and
you're like
all right I've I've stepped in the same
pile of whatever 100 times and I'm fine
I'll do it 101st doesn't hurt hell it's
good luck well hang on a minute maybe we
want to stop and go what can I learn
from that
but it it it
I don't know of a trick
I think I think that I think that I
think if there's any trick I would say
it's just it how quickly can we admit
the inevitable
I just want to talk about in the book
about because I get once you once you
know it's inevitable how do we get
relative yeah not skip it not throw it
to the side not deny it which I'd love
to talk about that here sometimes too
about the value of denial sometimes the
value of denial yeah
um but how quickly do we do we once
something's inevitable go
okay
any mind and hard time I'm spending
about going no I can't believe that
happened no or did that really happen
anytime we spend it trying to deny that
what has already happened that seems to
me to be I'm not sure the value of that
time
so if any if there's any trick I would
say once you know something's inevitable
even though how painful it is or how
awesome it is
start getting relative with that and in
the relativity is seeing
there's a gift here and if I realize
that gift I'm
honoring now I'm on to building up
the beautiful passage of my father
leaving this life now I'm on the march
to go yes let's let the Legacy let this
become omnipresent let him live through
me let me become more Hamlet